foreign
I invested in uh not I guess not not
just cryptocurrencies but investor in
companies and startups and then one of
those companies um was one that I
started um which was the uh the freedom
phone
foreign
I created my own phone we launched it we
did three and a half million dollars in
sales that first week and that's about
where the the Glorious story ends
because
um PayPal um and other payment
processors banded up uh not just
freezing on that money for what was
almost a year so we didn't even see a
single penny from customers customers
um said hey I want that phone and me as
the merchant at the time said hey I want
to give you this phone for x amount of
dollars and PayPal said uh-uh we're not
we're you have to ask us too and we
don't agree with that
of that first three and a half million
that came in that first seven days
1.2 million came through PayPal
um of which PayPal forcibly refunded
without the customer or us the
Merchant's permission eight hundred
thousand dollars
um and then didn't notify the customers
that they were refunded so they thought
that they bought a phone
um but they didn't and then they capped
about 450 000 of that
remaining so it was about 1.25 you know
million
um dollars so 800 000 force will be
funded 450 000
um just held for what was almost a year
on their terms of service so they can
only hold it for six months
um uh they they lied um also in their
terms of service it says when they hold
your money they can collect interest on
your money so they are making money by
not giving you your money to ship a
product to someone that wanted wanted to
give you money for
and it's not it's not a bug it's a
feature I mean this is a big fat Cash
Cow and PayPal was just one of them
they just hide behind automated emails
they just reference some weird section
0.33 that and then you just read the
section
um like the first section I got was just
you know we can do whatever we want I
mean that's I mean that's literally
that's literally what the section
basically meant do you know how tough
that was for them they just they scroll
but in my life's ruined for a year
that's that that is that is what
happened I'm I mean like three and a
half million dollars uh you know not
seeing a single penny of that for what
felt like eternity
um you know you're basically three and a
half million dollars in debt instantly
so when I saw the money come in I'm like
ah I'm I I you know I made it this is
great company
um this is an American success story so
I mean yeah I was in the fetal position
at the time I was praying you know worst
experience of my life ever period
um and and then also you know you the
customers like this like slowed us down
and shipping phones because I had to go
find money I had to go liquidate Bitcoin
assets to be able to ship phones and I
and I just you know I I look at would
any other company be able to ship a
phone ship it you know tons and tons of
phones without receiving a single penny
you know what also forces you into like
business decisions you do just a million
business decisions you would not make I
don't think it was ever as good as it
was gonna be but you know in my opinion
I think we would have done 10 million
dollars in sales by the end of the month
we did 5 million I think in total
throughout all that period of time I
firmly believe Freedom phone could have
been the next apple
I sold that company I don't own the
company anymore but now I'm suing
um these payment processors all together
on PayPal Amazon Shopify for 100 million
dollars
I knew that these payment processors
wouldn't do anything and this lawsuit's
going to take a long time the goal is
not just to win 100 million in Damages
the goal is to get them to change their
terms of service they do this you Google
it they just countless conservative
companies get screwed over by these
payment processors and not just
conservative companies you know
individuals like I said earlier
individuals that just get their money
Frozen for you know he was like well you
know you're one dollar above something
and some Metric they have internally
that they don't tell you and then you
know we're holding your money for four
weeks
I mean this was my baby you know I
believe in this so much I'm gonna take
the risk of that goal and that dream of
being the next apple that died when they
froze the money and that was their
intent from the beginning